We explored in part one of this topic,
a stitch pattern in the CB1 box is only
a design made of black and white boxes.
To create color work slip tuck or knit any
automatic stitch patterning technique,
the CB-1 box will select the needles,
and this, combined with the position
of the needles and the carriage settings,
are what create the stitch patterns.
Now, one of the fun things to do
with the CB-1 box is to combine designs
across the width of your fabric
for unlimited design possibilities.
We can break a stitch pattern up
into small elements and combine them
instead of creating one
large stitch pattern.
We'll use these two little motifs.
By themselves, they aren't very exciting,
but with a little imagination combined,
they can create an interesting
stitch pattern.
Start from the main menu and choose
the positioning program icon.
I'm using the cake carriage for my design,
but remember, this step gives you options.
We're going to isolate this exact design,
not have it all the way across
the width of the fabric.
This is where we set up
the combined pattern.
Motif 1 will be the little square.
It's pattern number 6 for me,
and I only want it repeated one
time horizontally on my knitting.
It will automatically repeat vertically,
so if I'd enter in 2 here,
I'd get the square side by side.
The next step is to position the motif
on the needle bed in relation to 0.
Since my motif is six stitches wide,
I'll enter 3 to position it.
Next, we'll set up the left zigzag motif.
Choose two and then enter
the pattern number.
Mine happens to be 901,
and indicate that you only want, again,
just one repeat of that pattern.
We can position that zigzag
anywhere we want.
Since it's six stitches wide, I'm going
to position it at needle number nine.
You can check your
positioning with the preview.
Use the arrow buttons on the direction key
to move the view and to double
check your positioning.
We'll do the same thing
for the other side of our design.
We'll position the zigzag
on the right side.
Choose motif 3,
enter in the stitch number.
Now it could be a completely
different motif.
I'm just using my zig.
Enter the number of repeats you want.
Position it in relation to 0 on the needle
bed or in relation to the other
motifs that you already entered.
You get an opportunity to preview
the positioning,
choose end, and you're ready to knit.